for those of you keeping score at home
last week was one for the Ruben report
record books our week started off by
interviewing Senator John McCain a war
hero one of the longest serving members
of Congress and a Republican nominee for
president of the United States Senator
McCain and I had a frank discussion on
this year's election money in politics
and foreign policy what struck me more
than anything while talking to the
senator was whether you agree or
disagree with his political opinions
it's clear that he's really trying to
bridge the ideological divide and do
what he feels is right for the country
the entire time I was talking to him I
kept thinking what a better candidate
Senator McCain would be than any of the
current contenders in the GOP rat race
immediately after interviewing Senator
McCain I had the chance to interview
Lube nuh Achmed Lumina is a 23 year old
engineering student and an atheist
fighting for secular values in her
homeland of Iraq simply by talking to me
about secularism from the confines of
her closed society she instantly became
braver than pretty much every person
that I know I'm honored that she chose
me as the first public person to talk to
and I'll always be an ally for her
whether she's in Iraq or wherever life
takes her while I was in awe of her
during the interview the most impactful
part to me was when we talked about some
of the people that we both admire
including sam Harris and Richard Dawkins
this portion of our chat illuminated
exactly what this show is about ideas
the same ideas that Sam and Richard
sparked in me a 39 year old guy born in
Brooklyn living in Los Angeles also were
sparked in lube nuh a 23 year old
atheist in Iraq this shows you the true
power of ideas good or bad ideas can
transcend nationality race or religion
my final interview last week was with
the former leader of the english defence
league and now outspoken anti
immigration activists tommy Robinson as
I mentioned at the top of the show last
week I was hesitant even talked to Tommy
because people might call me a bigot or
a racist not only my glad that we did
the interview but I'm really proud of
your reaction to it whether on YouTube
Twitter or Facebook you guys all kept
the conversation going after Tommy and I
put
down it was complete and total
confirmation of last week's direct
message being afraid to talk can no
longer be part of the equation I have no
doubt there is a real movement happening
right now people are absolutely sick of
being divided conversation is the key to
bringing us together and that's why in
one week I talked to a man who is almost
the leader of the free world a woman who
puts her life on the line to say what
she believes and another man who's on a
crusade of his own it's totally
irrelevant whether I agree with
everything my guests say the important
thing is to not be afraid to hear them
as the internet brings us all closer
together we find ourselves connected
with people in a way that we could have
only dreamt of a couple years ago
despite that connection I still get
messages from viewers explaining that
sometimes you guys are afraid to say
certain things to your friends in real
life or to post certain articles on
Facebook for all to see if lube nuh a 23
year old in Iraq isn't afraid to speak
up then you guys can't be either there's
no time for silence anymore yeah there
are genuinely bad people in the world
and sometimes talking to them won't get
you the results you want however you
have to be brave enough to have the
conversation in the first place don't
let louder voices with worse intentions
drown you out
you
I